spider-man trilogy Magic Mike True Blood
just three of the spots where we fell in
love with this man
he is Pittsburgh sports as there is as
anybody in narrative the documentary
about the Pittsburgh Penguins just a few
years ago die-hard Steeler fan and a big
time Thrones fan and a great friend good
to see you gentleman thanks rich great
seeing you it's man it's been a long
time it's been just last hours I said I
just saw you last night what uh what uh
I mean you put the other quite the
shindig like 2025 or your good friends
right close to close people yeah we sit
there food truck food truck little food
truck egde nice um Suzie provided the
cake amazing kid thrones k iron cake the
iron cake that when it opens up when you
open it up it's a red velvet blood cut
it in there yeah little red velvet cake
and it's funny
so Brockman with the the show ends
credits go down silence in the room and
then we start chirping about right just
saw horse Mike let's have some cake what
was the initial reaction by you well
I'll start this off sure I thought the
first half of it was amazing and the
amazing thing is that just as it
transitioned from John offing Daenerys
hmm and Daenerys goes off in the Talon
of her dragon pretty cool scene okay
amazing amazing
your wife heard the food-truck trying to
leave upstairs trying to smash there was
like an intermission and the bed oh my
god because there was like they were
ringing the doorbell frantically like
how do we get out of this driveway it
was a perfect place to cut it though it
was it's like it was like an
intermission it was just like it faded
to black even right yeah right the way
like Ghana with the wind was black and I
ran up had to open the garage
smash my world and then and then we came
back and it was like a different episode
it was a you know and I said to you
after is over it's amazing I'm making
this analogy but you ever see the movie
stripes hmm two different movies and the
first half was amazing yep and then the
second half you kind of like did you run
out of ideas like Full Metal Jacket is I
could not have been more disappointed in
the last 40 minutes of it the first 40
45 minutes amazing was tremendous a lot
of people that were very vocal in the
week previous about Daenerys destroying
all of King's Landing me being one of
them very controversial what did you
think of it well I had my thoughts about
it but then when I watched the first
half of the finale I thought I don't I
don't care what anybody said they had to
get to this point these shots are
beautiful I mean all the troops outside
of the red cape right this destroyed red
keep in the blizzard with the Targaryen
banner hanging I mean and then that shot
of her with the wings flap and then the
scene between her and Jon like I thought
you know what like it all was to get to
work that worked it was totally totally
worth having well I mean again though in
terms of Daenerys the the Khaleesi
destroying the town destroying King's
Landing I had such a problem with it
being two shows after she was fighting
for Humanity and then two shows later
she has no regard for Humanity it was
just a very quick Heal turn for me to be
able to swallow that said I was still
fired up I think the show is truly you
know culturally iconic for a reason sure
I was still fired up for that finale
last night and the way that they started
and picked it up from there all the way
through to Jon Snow
taking care of business mm-hmm
was remarkable I know some people have
had problems with the dragon not
torching Jon on the spot like sending
him to death but we'd rather well I mean
being a Targaryen you know what exactly
dragon if the dragon knew what also
dragons in the books have a human level
intelligence so I guess the debate can
begin about how much the dragon was
aware of what that throne meant right
apparently a lot apparently cuz Altima
was the Iron Throne that killed Danny
and so that's why I drogon melted the
throne sure it was her desire and quest
because that's all she talked about for
years and years and years so it was
almost the dragon saying I'm aware that
this is what did her in exactly woke
dragon was just a yep but I'm still I'm
still buying it Joe you know Joe
Manganiello here in the Rich Eisen show
I'm still buying it shows don't come
along that are culturally significant no
I know that I know that and I know that
you know your your friendly with one of
the creators of the show Dan Weiss he
comes in plays Dungeons & Dragons in
your house this was revealed on on
Instagram yes okay this is all right I
can yeah all right so what are you
coming over to play Rob you know what
he's trying to get he wouldn't know how
to roll the the multi uh Wow is this
like this like you're coming out to me
let's put a pin in it for a second I
just had a problem last night again with
it's now time to finish the show hmm
okay John snow
kills Daenerys the only evidence of him
killing Daenerys has been grabbed by a
Talon and flown off who knows where so
now we're cutting two just in the next
scene and it's really late really
excited three or four right and so John
walks out of after killing Khaleesi and
there's no evidence of it and he's just
like what he just reported himself to be
in his heart yeah exactly so so and then
his lineage that is codified in the
books that we could see somewhere his
actual claim to the throne nobody brings
it up when they're in this whole big
confab
nobody brings up oh by the way and the
guy who knows it is sitting right there
trying to bang the table for democracy
in Sam Tarly he doesn't bring up the
fact by the way the one guy who's locked
up is actually the rightful heir to the
throne he should have it that's not even
brought up at all and so that is just
bizarre that Tyrion then takes the stage
and reasons with the most unreasonable
people for the last eight seasons and
he's the prisoner to hang the table for
bran and brand who sits there and wargs
into everything whenever it's convenient
for him and then just sits on his ass
when it doesn't basically says why do
you think I'm here and it's just like
said then why the hell'd you send Theon
to his death and I mean like there's so
many different ways to just deconstruct
this right that upsets me so much to to
take aways from me okay one there's you
know there there has been a conversation
the zeitgeist about ambition being evil
yes and I think what Game of Thrones
argued or at least what the finale
argues is that ambition is not evil if
Jon Snow had the ambition to be king and
said no you know what I'm the rightful
heir I'm gonna set this right millions
of people wouldn't have died right so
it's not about ambition being evil it's
about being ambitious or the right
people being ambitious and then doing
the right thing with their power and if
he would have all those lives would it
be saved would have been said okay now
the other one the other takeaway is you
and I both we called Tyrion for the win
yes we did for the W now here's my
argument bran is not a demonstrative
King he's not somebody who's going to
step in and say don't do this or do that
based upon his infinite knowledge of the
past he just kind of hangs out this he
does so tyrion by default as the as the
hand of the king he's he's the king
Cheney
he's running Westeros so in a way we
should get partial credit or some kind
of points in terms of credit I mean I
went on
our survivor pool which again we'll get
to that in a second I'm Joe Manganiello
here in the Rich Eisen show I'm enjoying
this conversation so you did not have an
issue with the way the show ended last
night well I'll say this it was
unpredictable because I think in my mind
I thought I thought Daenerys would have
died during the the night King fight her
been turned yes and then the her dragon
would have been turned so there's two
ice dragons and her and the night king
and then I thought John would have had
to befriend drogon and then go off and
take down Cersei that's the way that I
pictured it that's what I thought was
going to happen now that I didn't so in
a way I was I was happy to be along for
the ride because I had no clue who's
gonna happen no look you and I discussed
this last night and before you came out
here as well I mean to have a show that
is so deep ingrained in the pop culture
landscape is so rare I'm gonna miss you
on Sunday night Susie coming over from
the food truck you need to get into
billions you need to gather into plow
zillions parties we could that wouldn't
be a bad way that's that's the next one
I'm gonna dive on a free four Dungeons &
Dragons rich we've got a few things to
dragons I wanna hit you know she's yours
wedding with you yeah but to me again
just the way that everything wound up
just got a little this the and Jon Snow
and encapsulate smite meant that his his
finish his end is worse off than what
happened to Cersei I know he's alive
absolutely but Cersei had a much better
finish it was a quick ending for her she
was with the person that she loved
despite it being weird yeah and with it
being her brother but that was important
to her at least she had that to that
John was brought back to life
for what he didn't even I guess getting
Daenerys involved in the the battle
against the night King was important but
what was he brought back to life for to
kill Daenerys as a tyrant I I mean and
then go back but
she wouldn't have gotten across the way
to be involved in all of this if it
wasn't for him it's just it just seems
to me just thrown and mashed together
and and so so they see that what is he
now is he the king beyond a wall that
doesn't need to be there anymore a lot
of like enforced celibacy that's gone on
in the show like I think that's another
bit take away like John's going off into
the woods to be celibate all of the
unsullied are going off to this Highland
to do who knows what the big dudes right
heading off to their Island together the
dragon kind of lonely unless it's it can
reproduce asexually I mean it's it's
kind of sad everybody was kind of you
know sansa on the throne kind of lonely
nobody there leaves gentry to go off on
the boat right but why does son why does
the north need to be separate her
brother is the king well also like okay
so all right you know what I want the
north to be independent well I was
waiting pretty but it yeah me too it was
just so neat and clean because Tyrion
spoke so eloquently it was just I don't
know yeah
it's not the way John and ghosts
reunited that was that was that was
awesome as a guy who worked for years on
an HBO show with Wolves I was really
upset that the wolf got no love I'm
sorry when he went out and patted Oh cuz
I used to have my wolf that played me on
True Blood and I used to get he liked me
he was to growl at everybody but he
liked me in real life in real life yeah
he liked me so they would let me walk
them and pet him and feed him and so I
like I miss that I miss that guy there
was our big tour man John Breaux hug
like they didn't really they just got up
together and then two rows back north
like there's yeah I mean look I again as
much as we questioning about it it still
was something that got folks like us
together it was fun to see dragon away
on screen I mean as a kid we didn't have
technology like that when I was little I
couldn't tell you you know my wife
brought the cake your wife has every
Game of Thrones item that's ever been
created in your house can you put up the
doorstop let's put it up here I have to
take a picture of this there's Chris
look at this there's the hole toward
ocean that's how you get this should
have bought stock in that thing before
we put this up yeah I know it's amazing
we have everything oh I also I'm a big
shout out to my cousin Jonathan yes who
got me all of the game of thrones
scotches they have house Baratheon House
Targaryen house they've got we've got a
white Walker sent me all the bottles so
thank you
Thank You cousin John's everything you
know everything in your hand yeah I know
it's totally cool and you brought what
did you bring the the cookies over there
what are the Game of Thrones Oreos what
do they have each each sigil on the
cookie so we have hampt on the cookie
yes they have the head a wolf we have
the dragon the night king which one do
you have over there Mike I have two of
my three characters by the way made me
may your may your all dude right now may
your may your survivor pool rest in
peace all of them how still 2fo is
crumbling like only one night Kings good
for what's the house they'll to folksy
Joel what's the symbol on the flag it's
a microphone is it okay
it's it what is a cargo short is it what
it is what is it Mike some think it's
about three people he's actually eating
an Oreo on a live radio television
simulcast first Oreo in like 10 15 years
and it's great huh it's really good okay
so before we all started the final
season we had a draft a snake draft
Brockman got the first overall selection
in our Rich Eisen show survivor pool
draft we get points for every episode in
which your character survives Mike
Brockman you chose Jon Snow on spec yeah
I chose bran stark is my first overall
pick del Tufo went back-to-back with the
night king and Daenerys came back and
when Sam Tarly I came back and when
Tyrion aunts Arya back-to-back him
and ethics onsen took Sansa and Mike
Dell to fulfill Cersei so I swept every
single character of mine survived scene
with you Brockman but our Thai break is
who sits on the crown is also a queen no
no no I get five six of the win you get
one second there's no Iron Throne
can you please brands Iron Throne it's
his wheelchair thank you sir by the way
did we put del two folds up like
tic-tac-toe Santa has a crown though
okay does she real own whatever
how was Shay's ears wedding sir it was
amazing like that guy is so inspiring
you know 18 months ago my friend Ryan
shazier was paralyzed in a football game
and told he was never gonna walk again
he was never gonna run around the
backyard to play with this kid and I got
to watch him walk down the aisle and get
married I got to watch him dance all
night I mean it was like it's incredible
he's such a positive inspiring force
that guy is incredible it was amazing so
and and look at the photograph we're
showing of his beautiful family on his
wedding day yeah yeah who was there
everybody all the Steelers all the brass
all the owners uh-huh
and it was great you know what James
Caan's Conner yeah he's awesome hung out
with Vance McDonald want to grabbing
dinner with Ben that over that weekend
with Charlie Batch and banners and
villanueva
Roethlisberger Big Ben he got he was at
the wedding too Pouncy yeah everybody
all the guys see I cam Hayward yeah the
whole gang juju and I've gotten to know
some of the guys over the years who
picked up the check
Ben did hey Ben did I try I went to the
bathroom pulled the like sneaky
bathrooms and Ben had gone I don't know
how he pulled it off but he but yeah he
got and there was like 20 people Ben
Roethlisberger could he be finally his
own nearly 40 year old man all groan
stuff no I mean seriously he has done it
before but it was interesting that he
did it again where he
for the first time I guess in a while he
brought everybody down to Georgia to
have a lab yeah and he's not doing his
radio show apparently it's a different
vibe this year I think because I get it
did you get that sense at the wedding
too very much very much I think it was
the team had fractured into individuals
and it's back to being a team now and I
also think that there's a lot of wind in
the sails because of the draft which I
have you and Michigan football to thank
for that Bush and that kid Gentry is
exactly good tight end for for Ben yeah
big huge the huge target Devin Bush it
is no joke man you're gonna love him I'm
getting you I'm gonna get you the first
bike out of the equipment yeah room
shirt for civilian use I'm gonna get you
the first Bush dry we'll take it man all
right I will take it yeah you're like do
you want to Michigan Devin Bush Jersey
is it like all my times exchanged I
would love it a jersey chanting I will
do a Jersey exchange with you done okay
great and we'll do it as I'm a cleric
putting on the cloak of invisibility
rolling the 20-sided die and you're in
your basement
just like getting back on a bicycle by
the way did you hear me did you hear me
done done and done walking through some
sort of back wives yeah I'm done now I
just just now I'm done with my dungeon
and Dragons but you know I don't know
you'll get me over there thanks again
for having me in Susie over oh please
any time you you have got a beautiful
home sir and a beautiful wife and a
beautiful setup and I you're lucky I did
not Fivefinger discount that Hodor
that's just my love for you the viewers
get rich thank you for the Oreos here
today yes many times
Joe Manganiello on Twitter and Instagram
as well that's right here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app